welcome to metaphysical milkshake I'm
your host Reza Aslin and I'm your other
host rain Wilson
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
are you playing the bassoon yeah yeah
I'm just I'm doing a little bit sooning
oh my God
normally I charge extra this would be
bonus material but we don't have a
patreon or anything like that so Jesus
Christ letting my weird flag fly you are
you are genuinely a weirdo like you are
like the real deal weirdo
hell yeah
but hell yeah I'm a weirdo
I fully embrace it
I fully embrace it
yeah my bassoon and chess playing self
and Dungeons and Dragons
and fantasy and science fiction reading
self fully has embraced my inner weirdo
you haven't welcome to metaphysical
Milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of Life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
look I even have for those watching on
our YouTube channel I even have a
bassoon
little keychain oh it's a little little
mini bassoon and that's a mini bassoon
yeah yeah uh do you have a it's like
having a picture of your girlfriend on
your desk listen it's very easy for you
to uh claim with pride your weirdness
when your weirdness has made you a
global celebrity I'm just saying okay
yeah I I have a feeling that this level
of of pride in your weirdness did not
exist when you were say 14.
uh no no it didn't it didn't I I have
talked about this before but um
I used to observe normal people
and I would try and imitate them
um I would observe normal human
interactions uh at the lunchroom or in
in restaurants and see how people would
shake hands and Pat each other on the
back and greet each other hey hey Scott
how was your weekend uh mine was pretty
good Mark how about you well I hung out
with Dave how's Dave doing well he's
doing pretty good actually uh he's uh
taken a few Strokes off his golf game
finally
and I would observe it almost like a
little alien child
um and strive to incorporate
um you know normal and regular human
interaction into into my regular
Behavior but obviously
that did not turn out so well now yeah I
mean I look I was I was weird not by
choice obviously I was an immigrant kid
uh you know could barely speak any
English but I you know I remember like
and I've again I have mentioned this
before in previous podcasts striving
very very hard
to not be weird to be like everybody
else to to you know to hide Who I Really
Am to pretend that I was something
something else someone else to try my
hardest
to fit in and uh and like I really I
really look back on those years and I
you know I kind of feel bummed about it
like I really feel like you know
I wish I would have had the
self-confidence necessary to just be
weird
and you know just like [ __ ] it like I'm
I'm a weirdo this is who I am
deal with it well the stakes were so
much higher for you you know for me it
was like just get the crap beat out of
me and get made fun of right but for you
it's like you need to fit in to this new
world America and Oklahoma or else
you'll perish you know what I mean there
was I imagine on some Primal traumatic
instinctual level you were like God damn
it Aslin like fit in get people to like
me be successful
it was my it was my monkey brain I was
like I was the caveman outside of the
cave going what do I need to do to get
shelter and fire fire and shelter what
must I do yeah that's I think that's
exactly right but how I wish
how I wish in those years that I had
some kind of like I don't know weird
icon some Paragon some Paragon of
weirdness a a North star a North star a
weird God that I could worship a North
star of weirdness that I could follow
and be like hey hey like that that works
that it works for that guy I could be
weird rain could be curly-haired giant
hatted
itinerant God of weirdness wait a wait a
second I think we might have someone
hold on I think we might have someone
uh a personal friend a dear personal
friend the weirdest guy that we know
the king of polka Alfred Matthew Weird
Al Yankovic known professionally as
Weird Al had a comedy song air in 1976
and he sold 12 million albums recorded
more than 150 parody songs at over a
thousand live shows five Grammys 11
nominations four Gold Records six
platinum records wow he's that God that
we have been looking for the god of
weird and uh he's got a new movie called
weird
the Weird Al Yankovic story it's uh it's
essentially a
semi-autobiographical
semi-fictional weird hybrid movie about
uh his life and his origin story and it
stars the one and only
rain Wilson Patton Oswald oh
more on that later
yes so excited to bring on the show uh
one of my mentors my Inspirations the
greatest one of the greatest of all time
um Al are you there Al
Al how are you
I'm good right thanks for asking
and yourself
I'm good it's been a little while it's
been a few months have you been I've
been okay I've been uh on the road uh
pretty much since I saw you last time we
started in uh late April I guess and
we're continuing on until the end of
October we finish up at Carnegie Hall in
New York uh but we it's a Non-Stop tour
I I'm not going to see my home for a
while how do you get to Carnegie Hall
don't well I was told that uh some
practice is involved
which you've been doing for 40 years but
that's correct most most importantly
um
how's the movie oh it's it's amazing for
those of you who don't know Rayne Wilson
was also in this movie played the great
Dr Demento who had a a pretty huge role
in your life Al right absolutely yes and
uh and rain was fabulous and uh Dr Mento
uh continues to be fabulous uh yeah he
gave me my start way back in the early
days and then played my stuff on the
radio one literally nobody else would
even think about doing so and uh yeah
he's a big part of my life and a big
part of this movie
now this is a serious question now
because uh people who have worked with
the brain will often say what a diva he
is on set
you know he doesn't like people to talk
to him or look at him in the eyes how
was that with you working working with
him on set you know people just came to
learn after a while that rain just gets
violent if you talk to him so they gave
him a space they gave him a little
bubble uh which and that worked out you
know everybody just kind of kept to
their own
so Al we're going to get into a pretty
deep conversation about what is weird
um and we're gonna wax philosophical and
and wax a little goofy at the same time
but before we go there
because we never even really got to have
this conversation but now that we're
like sitting because I for people who
don't know I was a last minute
replacement for Dr Demento um a certain
uh actor comedian who had originated the
role Robert De Niro uh broke their foot
De Niro close Patton Oswald
um Pat De Niro and uh so we didn't even
get to really sit down and have a
discussion but now that we have you here
like it's a little after the fact I know
you don't normally talk to an actor
about the real life character that
they've already portrayed months ago but
how tell us about Dr Demento how did you
meet him what was he like how did he
become kind of your your mentor and
supporter in those early days
well Dr Demento was sort of the dessert
at the end of the week uh on kmet Los
Angeles that was the big rock station in
La and it was just like straight ahead
almoriented Rock but every Sunday night
for four hours it was the Dr Demento
show and that was four hours of mad
music and crazed comedy it was novelty
and comedy just the wildest weirdest
stuff you'd ever hear on the radio and I
lived for that I mean it was like a
religious experience for me to hit the
documentary show and every once in a
while I would call up the request line
and he would actually pick up the phone
and I got to talk to Dr Demento I
thought wow amazing this is amazing and
uh it was a few years later that I
started getting invited to come down to
a show because I would send him
unsolicited tapes in the mail which he'd
play on the radio and again blowing my
mind uh and then he would have me come
down and answer phones at the radio
station and we got to be friends and and
we were friends to this day
so you were literally answering phones
for Dr Demento
that's incredible and what were people
were people requesting like I want to
hear uh
um Monty Python song from Life of Brian
and you you'd pass it on to to the good
doctors
I'm sure you want to hear the new Weird
Al song right
check that one out
no yeah
no there are actually several people
he'd have several people like uh he'd
have a whole uh a cast it was like a
party every week you'd have me and
musical Mike and uh Sulu and Damascus
and Beefalo Bill and all these crazy
crazy characters and we would just have
fun and hang out and answer phones and
make noises and blow on noisemakers
during the show
you know it must have been the weirdest
thing to like be on the set of a movie
about your own life uh is this is this
something that you wanted to do for a
while that you want to tell this story
for a while and what was it like
actually uh watching it unfold before
your eyes
well um it's something that we've been
pitching for a little while when we did
the original Funny or Die video that was
back in 2010 right and uh the movie is
very much a you know a movie version of
that Funny or Die trailer uh and back
then I thought you know this is really
really funny and the fans loved it but I
thought you know this is a three and a
half minute bit uh it is exactly what
it's supposed to be people like oh you
should do a movie like no it's a trailer
it works fine as is but then a couple
years ago all these movies started
coming out like uh Bohemian Rhapsody and
Rocket Man and these biopics that were
taking some pretty strong liberties with
the facts and using a lot of artistic
license and I thought well maybe we can
do a movie where we just kind of
throw uh versamillitude to the wind and
and uh basically just have a lot of fun
with it so by the end of the second act
I'm like battling a drug cartel you know
that kind of thing so so real life well
the thing I loved about uh the script
and I haven't seen the the finished
product out but I thought you guys did
such a masterful job of capturing a
really difficult tone where the movie
takes itself just seriously enough that
you can't it's not an airplane material
you know it's not a no it's not a
send-up but it's it's it's impossibly
absurd at the same time but it takes
itself deathly seriously how did you
guys find that that tone I guess that
was in the original Funny or Die uh
comedy sketch but it's really hard to do
what you guys did for a full 90 minutes
thank you for pointing that out yeah the
tone is very uh difficult and I give all
credits to Eric Appel the director for
that uh it's amazing yeah you hit the
nail on the head because it is it is a
comedy uh and it is very funny but the
tone is very serious and that's that's a
hard line to To Tread on because you
know there are some very serious
dramatic moments in the film they're
they're you know points in the movie
where people might get a little
teary-eyed I mean there's there's some
real you know real acting moments and
the same time there's some ridiculous
moments but it never there's we never
we're never winking we're never like
poking people around like ah you get it
you get it it's all done in a very
serious we wanted to all the traditional
uh biopic uh uh tropes uh and and and
and kind of send those up but at the
same time it's so I mean there's there's
some real information in there and
there's a lot of places where we we
tweak it a bit for comedic effect but
it's all done with a very straight face
so you never did date Madonna who was a
world uh famous gun Runner and uh drug
czar well for for legal purposes no I
have to say that uh that's never been
the case I imagine I met her once
briefly I think in 1985 uh at a some
kind of ceremony where she's being
presented with an award and we talked
for 30 45 seconds maybe so that's the
extent of my actual uh interaction with
her and uh she may or may not be
contacting me after this movie comes I
will find out yes I uh her lawyers might
be very very interested in the content
of this movie so we'll see what happens
fingers crossed 30 35 seconds that's
dating in my book yeah
we had a relationship
you know right and some people say that
coffee is a lot like pizza where like
even a not great cup of coffee is still
a cup of coffee it's still pretty good
no that's not true there's good coffee
and there's bad coffee and life is way
too short to drink bad coffee I'm one of
these people
uh yeah I drink a lot of coffee and I I
can't really tell you what it is that
makes a good cup of coffee taste so good
but what I do know is that whenever I
get my coffee from Trade coffee it is
always
fantastic what they do is they partner
with independent Roasters all over the
nation to Freshly roast and send the the
best coffees in the country direct to
your home on your preferred schedule and
listen your your coffee experience can
be as simple or sophisticated as you
want they taste test hundreds of coffees
from around the United States every
month to curate over 450 exceptional
coffees that make the cut or if you want
something curated just for you all you
got to do is just take a minute take the
coffee questionnaire it's an online
survey it's super simple and you'll be
expertly matched with your perfect
coffee and a fresh bag of beans will be
on its way flying to you the coffee I
get from trade is so good they even have
decaf coffees by the way and some
delicious ones and I can't believe I'm
actually saying that so trade is the
easiest way to get your very best
tasting coffee delivered fresh when you
need it so if you want to support small
businesses and through the the best cup
of coffee you've ever made at home it's
time to try Trade coffee and right now
trade is offering our listeners a total
of thirty dollars off your first order
plus free shipping all you got to do is
go to
drinktrade.com milkshake that's
drinktrade.com milkshake for 30 off your
subscription to the best coffees in the
country
it always drives me kind of a little bit
crazy when you're described as like a
parody you know songwriter or performer
or whatever because Jesus Christ you
have five Grammy Awards you have four
Gold Records you have six platinum
records your New York Times best-selling
author I mean you're like a global
Superstar and in fact this is the thing
rain and I were talking about this
earlier about like when we first started
like listening to Weird Al songs and it
occurred to us that we were about the
age that my sons are now and my son's
absolutely worship you in fact would it
be all right if I they would kill me if
I didn't invite them on to say hello
of course all right here we go of course
hey boys pass in your seat belt Al
because you're on the bus literally
fasten your literals you know I have a
lot I have a lot of children here comes
a bunch of Aslan hey all right how you
doing
this is Asa
this is Jeff how are you doing good
hello uh you know the one thing I'll
tell you about Jasper is that he has
really taken uh some real uh inspiration
from you and now he writes his own
parody songs it's just that they're all
about Minecraft
there's a market for that and then you
know
possibly Jasper can you sing one of your
parody Minecraft songs
[Music]
he's now ready for to perform just yet
but uh
anyway These Guys these guys were just
dying to meet you and anything you want
to ask any any questions for
Weird Al
[Music]
Starstruck Starstruck it's okay it
happens too oh the best of us so uh all
of that is to say you know you're
talking about generations of kids and
adults of course you know who've been
listening to you who who've grown up
with you who's whose kids are now
listening to you you know I I it's it's
funny to say this but like I'm not sure
if there is a rival to Weird Al Yankovic
like is there you know what I'm talking
about like people who have achieved a
certain level of success or stardom or
fame regardless of in what industry
you're talking about you can sort of
name two or three people who are
essentially you know they're Rivals that
that you know are that you kind of say
in the same breath
I honestly rain name someone name anyone
else in Weird Al's uh category okay I
have a funny story about this so
my friend uh Aaron Lee who's a comedy
writer knew these two other comedy
writers and they I don't even know if
you remember this happening Al they they
wanted to pitch a TV show that Al would
star in a reality show and it was like
find the next great song parody and they
met with Al that's a true story this was
like early 2000s and they're like wow we
want to do a show we find young song
parody people and you're like the
Godfather of song parody and then you
put the mantle on whoever the new song
parody person is and Al's response was
like
no are you kidding
this is what I do I do song parodies I'm
gonna do it for another 30 or 40 years I
don't want someone new I don't want to
bring on someone new this is this is my
gig this is this is who I am literally
about six different production companies
pitched me that exact same idea
like why do I want to find the next
Weird Al I'm still Weird Al
I'm still selling albums I mean your
last album was a when number was number
one I mean you're still you're still
relevant we wanted to get into the
essence of weird so weird is something
Reza and I have talked a great deal
about I know for me
in the in the early 80s when I was
coming of age there was no worse word to
be called than weird like if especially
if a girl called you weird
oh
you're weird it was just like it was the
kiss of death to be called weird and I
was
terrified of that of being thought of as
weird and yet I fully embraced weird and
I was as many of our listeners know at
the same time I was on the chess team
the marching band where I wore a kilt
and played the xylophone wow I played
the bassoon
I was on Model United Nations and
um and the pottery club and these were
all at the same time so there was none
stranger at Shorecrest High School in
Seattle and I it was I was mortified but
it was it was just who I was I couldn't
I couldn't separate myself from my
identity as weird but Al what was you
what was your story of weird how did you
how did you come to embrace this this
moniker that I am sure began as a label
of great shame and humiliation and then
you you spun it into gold
my upbringing was very close to yours I
never played the bassoon uh or you know
went to the United Nations but other
than that you know I I was a
prototypical nerd you know I was uh
always getting by myself or with one or
two other similar nerds at the lunch
table at school and uh you know you have
to understand back then being a nerd was
not something you aspired to I mean
nowadays like you'll have like hot women
saying oh I love nerds I've always been
a nerd myself and that was not the case
no it was not uh but but hold on a
second because let me stop you right
there because uh Reza we've talked about
this before that's ridiculous you have
like Charlize Theron and and Jessica
Alba and like these incredible you know
all of these top movie stars and they're
like I was a nerd in high school I like
the nerd it's like [ __ ] you did not
give me a break
a you were not a nerd and and B you
didn't talk to nerds give me come on
Jennifer Aniston really you hung out
with him no you did not
there was definitely a Tipping Point I
don't know like like 15 years ago or so
I think there was a Tipping Point where
nerds became kind of cool like certainly
when we were growing up it was not the
case but I I don't know exactly what was
on the water or the air but all of a
sudden people were like oh yeah nerds
are okay they make all the shiny toys
they're all right uh and then all of a
sudden people they'll look like Napoleon
Dynamite are hipsters and they're cool
and you aspire to look like I looked in
high school for some reason I was just
gonna say you never played the bassoon
but you were in the volcano worshipers
Club in high school which kind of worse
maybe sort of worse well you know that
was uh that was strictly a a gag there
we never had a single meeting I started
the club just so I could get an extra
picture of myself in the yearbook
that was the whole deal so we took a
picture and called ourselves the volcano
worshipers and that was all that there
ever was of that
I don't understand why anyone would find
you weird it doesn't make any sense at
all no I can't run for president though
because they'll look at my high school
yearbook you're the volcano worshipers I
don't know that's right yes that's the
only reason you can't run for president
that's the only reason so you know it's
kind of common knowledge people who are
familiar with you know that you got the
the nickname Weird Al in I guess it was
College dormitory yeah um yeah you were
younger than everybody else there a bit
of a of an outcast I mean you were you
know a semi-professional
um you know accordion player that that
tends to that tends to get noticed but
what I'm what I'm curious about is
you know you I mean clearly it was meant
as an insult and and I I would imagine
you understood it as an insult
what do you think
it meant like what do you think people
were saying when they called you weird
like what were they reacting to what
were they what were they saying about
you well just that I was outside the
norm I was different I was unusual I was
making them uh uncomfortable with my
behavior apparently
um and when I decided to call myself
Weird Al uh you know I just took on you
know in retrospect it was I guess it was
a form of empowerment but I didn't
really know like the ramifications that
would happen like decades after the fact
like uh I sometimes I wonder like did I
make the right decision like branding
myself with Weird Al because now I'm
like weird out my whole life but I've
heard so many from so many people that
felt you know uh like they were
diminished uh in the eyes of others
because they were different or unusual
or weird that you know here's a guy that
was like feeling okay about being weird
he was Weird Al and for those people uh
it made them feel better about
themselves that made them feel like it
was maybe okay that they were a little
bit different actually did I have a
story about that my other son who
unfortunately you didn't get to see
because he's upstairs I have a very
clear memory this is maybe about a year
ago or so that uh he came home from
school and he said uh
you know I asked him how school was or
whatever and he said you know the the
Mean Girls there's a group of Mean Girls
of course even in elementary school
there's always a group of Mean Girls the
Mean Girls called me weird
and I said oh man I'm you know
immediately I'm I'm back to my childhood
and I said I said oh man uh buddy I'm
I'm sorry about that you know that's
these girls are mean and it's okay and
he's like no I actually said to them
that's right I am weird and I love being
weird it's like I am weird and that's
cool that's what I am I was like wow
like that is I'm sorry but when I was 11
10 11 years old if a girl called me
weird that was it for me that was it the
oh man and I really do think that a huge
part of it has to do you know with what
you were saying that the the kind of
using this derogatory term as a as a as
a you know a form of empowerment like
taking it on and saying damn right I'm
weird that's what it's going to be weird
and it's something that he's carried
with him so great to hear wow and I
think how that's why you're a hero to so
many as you paved the way for so much
oddness I mean you had talked about that
tide that turned about about 16 or 20
years ago I think it was Beck I think it
was Beck combined with Rivers Cuomo from
Weezer
um that all of a sudden defined oh my
god there are rock stars who are nerds
um yeah and I want to say too for the
record
I know Al a long time ago you reached
out to me to be in the video of white
and nerdy I could have been in the video
for white
but I I I was busy or I was shooting or
I was somewhere and I didn't I couldn't
do it and that's one of the great
regrets I have in my life but oh
changing gears a little bit so the word
weird we did a little research on it it
used to mean Destiny it used to mean
controlling Destiny it has had to do
with the fates yeah and that all of a
sudden Shakespeare used uh weird in
Macbeth can you say Macbeth on a podcast
um I think you can think it's all right
and uh all of a sudden and weird became
yes Fates and Destiny the witches were
the kind of the Fates you know
controlling Macbeth's fate but they were
also odd and and they were just quite
frankly weird so the word actually
became what it means today which is odd
or offbeat or what have you but [ __ ]
Shakespeare right [ __ ] Shakespeare
ruins everything do you what is your
definition Al of uh of weird well I
looked I looked at up before this
podcast on on Marion Webster and the
second definition is of relating to or
caused by Witchcraft and that's the
definition I release the most with
because uh most of my songs are in fact
made by witchcraft so I think they're
spot on but there is something really
interesting about this because like I
guess
weird is one of those words where you
have to believe that there is such a
thing as normal in order to believe that
there's such a thing as weird right like
we all have to agree what is normal for
someone to be weird but like
is there even such a thing as normal
Alec is that a thing well it's a
societal it's it's whatever people
decide normal is like what's normal to
somebody will be weird to somebody else
uh like if you were to drive a horse and
buggy down Fifth Avenue uh uh well
that's not a great example because New
Yorkers don't really think anything's
weird they probably wouldn't bat an eye
but I mean that would be unusual for
them but probably not so much for
Ezekiel back on the Amish farm you know
yeah so um believe it or not in
preparation for this conversation Al um
we had an epic research doc prepared
about weirdness and psychological
studies having to do with weirdness and
we found out some really interesting
stuff there was for instance a study
that was done by Sharon Kim at Johns
Hopkins University business school where
she was wondering if social pariahs are
actually more creative so
she created teams of people and some
people were just rejected randomly from
the teams and they were given tasks so
there were the people who fit in and
then they were the rejects and the tasks
were to be creative to do a bunch of
exercises Etc and
um and to also to draw an alien from a
planet very unlike our our own
um and they found in this study that the
rejects were were better at all the
exercises and for even especially the
alien task the the people who fit in in
the experiment Drew aliens that were
kind of like cliched martians and and
whatnot but the rejected participants
Drew these really imaginative
beautifully designed aliens that looked
radically different from humans
all these appendages sticking out of
their body
Etc onwards so they have found that
being a social pariah
being a reject being an outcast actually
leads to far greater creativity
I would agree 100 I think there's a
direct correlation between weirdness and
creativity because weirdness by almost
by definition is thinking outside the
box I mean Apple had that whole
marketing campaign a number of years ago
think different which was you know a
long very similar line like all the
great world leaders and all the greater
inventors or people who think
differently and I think that the
campaigns should have been just be a big
freaking weirdo because that's the same
thing essentially like you know like
your weird freak flag fly like you know
that's where the creativity comes from
it's not from like going along with the
norm it's from you know beating beating
your own drum yeah and it's it's
actually really it makes so much sense
too because of this notion that the the
the people who were in a group
had to constantly you know like talk
about ideas talk about like what they
how they would answer the question what
what is our alien going to look like and
it just kind of reduces everything to
that sort of Base Norm
but if you have no one if you have no
one telling you that's stupid that's
weird don't do that if you have no box
right to be trapped inside of then it's
very easy to think outside of it and
it's not by the way just creativity the
same is true for Innovation and
inventiveness and then here's where it
gets really weird so it turns out
that you know weirdos by which we just
mean the social outcasts it's okay maybe
we should stop using that phrase but you
know what I'm saying
um I can say it because I am one not
only not only do they have like these
creative strains in these Innovative
strains because they can think you know
outside of the box and all that stuff
they're not like you know limited by
societal ideas of what is right and Etc
but they can also develop these ways to
calm their social anxiety in a way that
people who actually aren't you know used
to being in crowds cannot which which
seems counter-intuitive right like if if
you're you know an outcast if you're a
weirdo usually that has a lot to do with
social anxiety but it turns out that the
very Act of being alone
oh you know a lot of being on the
outside a lot creates far greater
comfort with yourself
than the act of constantly having to
perform for a group constantly having to
be you know like everyone else so in
this weird way it's like weirdness
becomes this crazy superpower that you
know we we are only now starting to
understand
it's it's interesting that way because
um the people that uh have that kind of
mindset uh tend to develop a lot of
self-confidence in a weird kind of way I
always think about a guy that was on my
in my uh College in my math class
freshman year who had come to class sit
in the front row and bring a box of like
Captain Crunch cereal in a bowl and eat
breakfast during class there's no rules
saying he couldn't sometimes he'd show
up Barefoot to class and people are so
the weird guy the weird guy he didn't
care he was living his life he wasn't
hurting anybody you know he was just
doing his own thing right and that's
what I think is is surprising right
because I guess when you really break it
down it does make sense like if you
don't give a [ __ ] what anyone thinks
about you and your Captain Crunch
then in a strange way far from
developing what we think weirdos develop
like social anxiety and you know
awkwardness in reality like you're
supremely confident if you're walking
around with an accordion if you're
wearing a kilt and playing the xylophone
in front of people then you're actually
fairly confident in who you are yeah I
think sometimes you know I can't speak
from experience but I think sometimes
people that that indulge in alcohol and
Controlled Substances I think they're
looking for an excuse to be weird I
think they secretly they want to be
weirder than they are in normal life but
they don't have an excuse for that kind
of behavior so they you know go that
direction I I thought you were going to
end your story about the Captain Crunch
guy by saying um and the name of that
student Jeff Bezos you know I thought I
was waiting for like the caption but I I
know I know for me Al
uh you know I think I'm a pretty funny
guy and can play some pretty funny
characters but I don't think that I'm
any kind of like comedic genius or
anything like that I I I and you know
far far from it
um I'm just a comic character actor and
I know how to play weird characters and
um but I do think that because I was
such an outcast in school that it
comedy comes from being weird I think
humor is generated from that pressure
cooker of of of not of not fitting in
you've got to find other ways to relate
to people because I I never was easy
going I just was never like the ease you
know the popular I would watch the
popular kids I remember studying them
and they were just they were so easy
going and be like hey bro how's it going
hey good how was your weekend hey
excellent are you gonna have the tuna
salad uh I don't know
um hey what's molly up to I don't know
she's she seems down in the dump like I
would watch their conversation I'm like
wow that how do they relate to each
other with just such ease and
effortlessness and for me just a
conversation was just so awkward and
difficult but that that that that that
that that energy that went inside me and
then and then it came out sideways and I
had to learn to to fit in by being the
class clown making people laugh quoting
Monty Python sketches
um you name it and I think that that
particular petri dish of being
ostracized gave me a career
yeah you know I hear a lot of comedians
say that a lot of Comedy come from from
pain or suffering or some traumatic
experience that certainly was my
experience I mean I had a fairly
abnormal and happy childhood but I
obviously did have that Outsider status
thing going on I never felt like I
belonged I was always in fact in fact
when I started my career uh my whole
thing was I was this this weird kid from
La that was like poking fun at the elite
people all these rock stars inside this
hermetically sealed bubble of Pop Pop
Fame and uh it was I actually enjoyed
that status and that you became a little
the lines got a little blurry after a
few years when I was like winning
Grammys and showing up at the same
Awards shows I just these people I was
making fun of and all of a sudden I was
sort of like in the bubble with them and
it became like a little bit of a
different Dynamic but but starting out
certainly having that Outsider status
was was critical to developing this kind
of a comedic Persona here you are now
decades into this incredibly successful
career and we he also talked about the
fact that weirdness nowadays apparently
is cool like that's a thing now where
like nerds get get the the girls and uh
weird people you know get to be uh
popular at school and stuff and so I
just wonder if like
not just for in your particular case but
just in general in society has the
popularity of weirdness kind of changed
the power and efficacy of weirdness we
just talked about how weirdness is this
crazy superpower this unexpected
superpower but if like weirdness is a
positive now or if it's popular now
does it is it no longer weird I guess
this is what I'm saying you know I think
um
I don't think people are getting weirder
I think as as a species we've always had
about the same percentage of weirdness
sprinkled Among Us uh but I think we
have more access to show off our
weirdness that's the thing uh because we
have the internet we have social media
uh back when I was starting out the only
place where you I could show off my
weirdness was the Dr tomato show that
was basically it that was the only
Outlet uh and now anybody with a
camcorder or a laptop uh can get their
stuff out there and we see a lot more of
it we see how weird we really are and
it's uh it's exciting and scary and all
the emotions but uh but we're starting
to really see what we look like and
sound like and feel like amazing well Al
listen you've been a hero of mine since
I was 16 and heard you uh Play Another
One Rides the Bus on the Dr Demento
Radio Show in Chicago one Sunday evening
and uh the fact that I got to be in your
movie playing Dr Demento is just again a
bucket list checklist item uh this movie
is going to be fantastic people are
salivating to to watch it thank you for
having me be a part of weird the Al
Yankovic story and and for and for
coming on the show for for being a
Pioneer to allow all of us to let our
freak flags fly
um you truly are a living God and thank
you I would that went somewhere
oh uh you're the best you were a
phenomenal in the movie I know you
haven't as of right now you have not
seen it yet you were phenomenal
hilarious I cannot wait for you to see
it thank you for the Kudos I love you
dearly
um I will uh see you in real life
someday one of these days good good luck
on your tour I also also want a big
shout out to Patton Oswald thank you for
breaking your foot and
enabling the the understudy to step in
to the shoes Dr Demento
good luck with the rest of the tour Al
thanks so much for coming on the show
thank you
you know rain hearing you tell that
story to Al about um you know being
Patton Oswald's uh stand in reminds me
that the original idea for this podcast
was actually me and Patton Oswald like I
you know Patton got in touch with me he
was like hey maybe we should do like a
little a podcast together and I was like
yeah that sounds great
um and then I think Adam Oswald is into
life's biggest philosophical spiritual
and psychological questions of humanity
yeah yeah yeah I had no idea but anyway
long story short he couldn't make it and
then uh and then you stepped in so I
really feel like that's a that's kind of
a pattern wow how about that you know
it's it's amazing Reza in this
conversation I had never thought of it
before but um you mentioned it actually
um in our preparation for the episode
and and during the course of it that you
know is weirdness a superpower and I
think that's really brilliant because I
think about me and my friends I think
about the artists and the Misfits I
think about the rock stars that that I
love the kind of music that I like the
the innovators that I look up to there's
a certain element of Misfit in them yeah
um which gives them
uh actual powers to transform their
their Oddity their pain into Beauty into
entertainment I think you really hit on
something I I feel like there's this
could be like a book deal I it's true
I've never really like thought about it
until this conversation but like
you know when you're when you're popular
or when you're part of the crowd
and everybody who's listening to this
knows exactly what I'm talking about
I don't think that's our audience you
find yourself that's true you find
yourself
constantly changing in order to meet the
crowd where it's at do you know what I
mean like if the crowd's like hey we all
love you know football then you're like
yeah football and you start to like
football or if they're crazy wait a
minute you and I both really like we
love football that was bad but like or
if the crowd is like that guy sucks you
know you start to kind of
go along with the sort of okay well that
guy sucks or it's this weird group think
that happens
when you try to
conform and belong and it's involuntary
you don't really think about it I mean
I'm basically just describing my entire
childhood as trying to change who I am
in order to belong but when you are
told from the beginning you don't belong
you've you have nothing to conform to go
to your corner you're you're not like us
you're an outcast
it creates this sense of like when you
don't need to perform anymore right you
can really just be who you are and think
what you think uh and feel what you feel
and when you think about it now like of
course it makes so much sense of course
that those weirdos tend to become the
innovators and the inventors and the
creators and the performers
um the people who think outside of the
box because they're not trapped in the
Box you know uh it's really it's kind of
an inspiring
thought right I mean it's really I wish
I wish someone would have told me that
when I was 12. yeah I also think that
um when you're popular and well-liked uh
and you know God I wish I I had that
test of being popular and well liked but
I don't think you have to try as hard to
fit in it's easier to settle I think you
know if if you don't have to actually be
funny to get your jokes laughed at if
you don't have to try something
different and unique to be uh to be
liked or appreciated you're just kind of
naturally liked and appreciated for who
you are in other words well balanced
um so does this mean that in the future
Reza let's say there's some utopian
future where there's no bullying and
people are just loving to one another
and accepting of everyone's differences
and diversities
um does that mean that creativity will
be lost the innovators will be will be
lost put another way
if weirdness becomes the new normal then
is there any weirdness left
I don't know thou whoa that's a question
for our milkshakers to ponder upon uh
let us know what you think you can find
us on social media at Reza Aslin and at
Rayne Wilson and on Twitter at metamilk
podcast and on Instagram at metaphysical
milkshake let us know
what you think about the future of
weirdness uh and uh remember to follow
rate and review us on Apple podcast or
wherever else you listen to podcasts and
you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake YouTube channel
see our full episodes every week you
could actually get to see Weird Al in
that awesome hat in a tour bus uh
talking to
fellow weirdos fellow weirdos indeed and
we'd love to hear from you too like what
what superpower did your weirdness give
you you can write us as well at
metaphysical castmedia.com that's cast
with a K we'd love to hear from you
thanks so much for watching slash
listening everyone we'll see you next
week metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rain Wilson Reza Aslan and
Colin Thompson it is produced by Safa
samasade yazd Paris Lane mcdamaria
Hashem South and DJ lubel cast media is
the production and distribution partner
original music by Jeff Tang
foreign
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
YouTube channel thank you